I'm cooking for bozos desert dinner
party tonight and he's teaching me a
slow-cooked meat dish called could gut
gosh made with goat there's nothing much
no there's no finery in this near
tamasha i said college in india so this
is basically tenderizing the go it's
just and raising the good this is
something you grew up with this is what
yeah this is pretty much the kind of
stuff where one sort of always grew up
seeing all the elders like something
uncle's in there with my father they
were in cookie when we are without
shooting initially now with the masalas
the goat leg will be smothered in a
masala mix made with chili and turmeric
and now local spices very indigenous to
Rajasthan you won't probably get it
anywhere else it's something which we
call it over here country country yeah
and it's a family it's it works as a
tenderizer it also still gives it that
little tangy flavor fresh kateri comes
from a small brown melon and it's only
found in radish town mix the game miski
Wow this helps to keep it juicy mm-hmm
you know things dry up too much now
comes the surprising bit we moisten sack
cloth and muslin then lay banana leaves
on top which we'll use to wrap up the
goat now what we need to do is get the
Indian bread with you thread the chapati
is passing so it's almost like a
Wellington like a goat Wellington we
have a filler beef wellington
okay a traditional you know sort of 70s
retro dish wrapped in a pancake
then pastry okay it's lined with
mushrooms that's that's the general idea
it's a whole meal itself yeah yeah this
particular recipe was taught to me by
one of our old old family chefs
he's still around can't see very much
but he's he's nice probably one of the
best cooks I've known now for the messy
part right what do you have to do steak
the masala massaging massage it into the
meat and the
to spread it around but on everywhere
yes okay good so I can see bozos not a
man that likes getting his hands dirty
he's used to having servants around so
okay here we go
take this Wow sorry to hold that as I've
come as you come around I think it'll
hold itself now okay cuz you want to
wrap it up yeah [ __ ] see you next
Tuesday gonna come back a mark we need
you we need to do the ditch come back
please
please Gordon please come back
we can't finish it without you thank God
I wasn't your chef in your palace any
years ago I swear to God
your wife's crispy would never be the
same trying to hold it on there for you
cigarette the rest
I think bozo considers me good
belowstairs material I know the little
[ __ ] you want me to do chef
[Music]
now we wrap it up we just need to build
water to just be tied up and this 300
years recipe is ready
[Music]